สวัสดีค่ะครูฟ้าสวัสดีค่ะนักเรียนสวัสดี
ค่ะครูหญิงสวัสดีค่ะครูฟ้าวันนี้วันอะไร
คะวันนี้
นะวันนี้วันเสาร์ค่ะวันที่เท่าไหร่คะวัน
ที่
4 เดือนอะไรคะเดือน
กุมภาพันธ์ปีพ.ศอะไรคะคะปีพ.ศ
2566 ปีค.ศอะไรคะปีค.ศ
2023 ค่ะค่ะเมื่อวานนี้วันอะไรคะเมื่อ
วานนี้วันศุกร์วันที่เท่าไหร่คะวันที่
3 เดือนอะไรคะเดือน
กุมภาพันธ์ปีพ.ศอะไรคะปีพ.ศ
2566 ค่ะปีค.ศอะไรคะปีค.ศ
2023 ค่ะค่ะพรุ่งนี้วันอะไรคะพรุ่งนี้
วัน
อาทิตย์สีแดงมั้ยอ่ะวันที่เท่าไหร่คะวัน
ที่ 5 เดือนอะไรคะเดือน
กุมภาพันธ์ปีพ.ศอะไรคะคะปีพ.ศ
66 ค่ะปีค.ศอะไรคะปีค.ศ
2023 ค่ะค่ะตอนนี้กี่โมงแล้วคะครูฟ้าตอน
นี้ 1:00
น 1 กี่
นาที 1  27 นค่ะค่ะอีก 3 นานาทีก็จะเป็น
1:30 นแล้วนะคะตอนนี้ก็เป็นตอนเวลากลาง
คืนู่ฟ้า 1:00 นอ่ะแต่เรา 2 คนยังไม่ได้
นอนครูหญิงรู้สึกหิวค่ะหิวครูหญิง 1:00 น
แล้วครูหญิงจะกินอะไรคะครูหญิงเนี่ยก็ครู
ฟ้าเนี่ยครูฟ้าไม่เคยกินตอน 1:00 นเหรอคะ
กินค่ะ
ครูฟ้าจะถามครูหญิงทำไมครูหญิงหิวแล้วก็
คิดว่าอยากกินอาหารทะเลอ่ะค่ะครูฟ้าเพราะ
ว่าครูฟ้าเนี่ยอยู่พัทยาใช่มยพัทยาเนี่ย
เป็น
ทะเลทะเลก็ต้องมีต้นมะพร้าวนะคะนักเรียน
เนี่ยครูฟ้าอยู่พัทยาทะเลก็อยากกินอาหาร
ทะเลอยากกินปลา
หมึกอยากกิน
กุ้งอยากกินปู
อยากกินฉลามได้
มยกินฉลามกนามเหรอผู้หญิงได้ใช่มยได้มย
อ่ะคะอยากกินปลาหมึกปลาหมึกก็ออไม่เอา
อยากประมาณ
20%
30% อยากกินปูประมาณ
99.999% ค่ะครูหญิงคะแล้วครูหญิงจะให้
ครูฟ้าเนี่ยว่ายน้ำ
ไปเก็บูให้ครูหญิงเหรอคะไปค่ะเพราะว่าครู
ฟ้าอยู่พัทยาอยู่ทะเลครูฟ้าต้องเข้าใจปู
มากกว่าครูหญิงครูหญิงเนี่ยปูจับปูยังไง
คูหญิงไม่เข้าใจค่ะแต่ครูฟ้าเนี่ย
เก่งรใช่มถึงครูฟ้าจะเป็นคนพัทยาแต่ครู
ฟ้าไม่ใช่ปูนะคะแต่ที่พูดถึงปู
เนี่ยอะไรคะครูฟ้าปู
ค่ะอันนั้นปูอ่ะเข้าใจแต่มันคืออ๋อมันคือ
ตาของปูอันนี้เป็นก้ามปูใช่มั้ยเป็นก้าม
ปูนี่เป็นขา
ปูนี่คือปูนะคะครูฟ้าก็เลยมีเรื่องมาเล่า
ให้ครูหญิงฟังเรื่องเกี่ยวกับปูเหรอเหรอ
คะครูฟ้าคสเรื่องเกี่ยวกับปูค่ะหิงครูฟ้า
พูดอะไรนะคะครูหญิงฟังไม่ค่อยได้ยินครู
ฟ้าบอกว่าแน่นอนนะคะเรื่องเกี่ยวกับ
ปูแล้วเรื่องที่ครูฟ้าจะมาเล่าให้ฟัง
เกี่ยวกับปูเนี่ยมันชื่อเรื่อง
อะไรชื่อเรื่องว่าแม่ปู
กับลูกปู
อ่าแล้วพ่อปูไปไหนล่ะนะคะขนาดครูฟ้าเนี่ย
ยังมีพ่อมีแม่แล้วก็
ฟ้าใช่มยแต่ว่าอันเนี้ยมีแค่แม่ปูกับลูก
ปูพ่ออยู่ไหนพ่อปูก็อยู่ในท้องครูฟ้าไง
ครูฟ้ากินกินไปแล้วก็เลยเหลือแต่แม่ปูกับ
ลูกปูโอเคค่ะแล้วเรื่องมันเป็นยังไงคะครู
ฟ้าาละครั้งหนึ่งนะ
[เพลง]
มาพอแล้วค่ะซูมตัดเสียงกาละครั้งหนึ่ง
นานมาแล้วนะคะ
ค่ะ
จบไม่ใช่สิยังไม่มีเรื่องปูเลยแค่พูดว่า
กาละครั้งหนึ่งนานมาแล้ว
เองที่แถวๆทะเลนะคะทะเลที่ทะเลที่ทะเล
ทะเลอือืทะเลแสน
งามใช่ค่ะนี้ก็จะเป็นต้นมะพร้าวใช่มั้ยคะ
นักเรียนทะเลที่ไหนคะทะเลประเทศไทยทะเล
ญี่ปุ่นทะเลเกาหลีทะเลออสเตรเลียทะเล
ฮาวายทะเลไทยค่ะเพราะว่าปูพูดภาษาไทยนะคะ
โอเคค่ะทะเลพัทยานั่นเองนะคะทะเลที่พัทยา
ค่ะตรงนี้ก็จะเป็นชายหาดใช่มั้ยนักเรียน
ชายหาก็จะมีทรายใช่มั้ยมีทรายเนี่ยครูฟ้า
ก็ไปนอนอยู่ที่นี่ได้นะคะอืแล้วก็มีทราย
รายๆๆๆๆๆๆอืเป็นชายหาชใช่ค่ะที่ชายหาด
เนี่ยนะคะครูหญิงมีครอบครัว
ปูอยู่กันเต็มเลยอ๋อก็เหมือนเป็นบ้านเนาะ
เป็นบ้านบ้านบ้านแล้วก็เป็นบ้านปูๆๆๆแต่
ปูไม่ได้อยู่ในบ้านิปูอยู่ใน
รูใช่มยใช่อยู่ในรูแล้วปูก็เดินใช่ค่ะออน
แหละและที่ชายหาดเนี่ยนะคะก็ไม่ได้มีแค่
ปู 2 ตัวนะแต่มีครอบครัวปูอเยอะมากปูๆๆๆๆ
ประมาณ 8,000 ตัวอือหกี่ครอบครัว
เนี่ยเยอะมากใช่มั้ยใช่ค่ะครูฟ้า
อืและก็รวมถึงปูตัวนี้แล้วก็ลูกด้วยนะคะ
คุณแม่ลูกก็หมายถึงรวมใน 8,000 ตัวหรือ
ว่าในครอบครัวที่อยู่ที่ชายหานี้เนี่ยก็
รวมครอบครัวปูปูสีชมพู 2 ตัวนี้ด้วยใช่
ค่ะรวมปูสีชมพู 2 ตัวนี้นะค่ะค่ะอ่ะแล้ว
ยังไงต่อคะแม่ปูกับลูกปูเนี่ยนะคะชอบเดิน
เล่นชอบร้องเพลงด้วยกันอืมเราบอกว่าแม่
ลูกร้องเพลงอื
ออร้องเพลงนะคะแม่แม่ร้องเพลงอือลูกก็
ร้องเพลงใช่อ่าแม่
เต้นลูกก็เต้นตอย่างเงี้ยเหรอโอหนี่ท่า
เต้นของซิกเนเจอร์ครูฟ้าเลยนะคะนักเรียน
ไอ้ท่าอะไรของเ้าเนี่ยว่าชอบมากนะคะแม่ปู
กับลูกปูเนี่ยชอบทำอะไรสนุกๆด้วยกันอืม
เล่นกีตาร์นะคะร้องเพลงเต้นดู netflix นะ
คะค่ะแงครูฟ้าหรือเปล่าแต่ว่าชอบทำอะไร
ด้วยกันใช่มยชอบทำอะไรด้วยกันค่ะแล้วก็
มีอยู่วันนึงนะคะครูหญิงเกิดอะไรขึ้นคะ
ลูกปูก็บอกว่าวันนี้อากาศดีมากเลยแม่ลูก
เนี่ยนะอื
อือากาศดีมากเราไปเดินเล่นกันดีมยเดิน
เล่นเดินเล่นแล้วเพราะว่าอากาศดีเนาะถ้า
อากาศหนาวก็อากาศไม่ดีถ้าฝนตกก็อากาศไม่
ดีอื
ก็เลยชวนแม่ไปเดินเล่นแล้วคุณแม่ไปมยหรือ
ไม่ไปลูกแม่จะ
นอนคุณแม่บอกว่า
อืมวันนี้อากาศดีจริงๆอากาศดีแบบนี้เนี่ย
นอนไม่โอเคหรอกต้องไปเดินเล่นไปอาบแดดนะ
คะี้เหรอคะอันนี้คือูฟ้าดแล้วก็อาบแดด
อือ่าอาบแดดเปลี่ยนสีผิวใช่มยเปลี่ยนปูก็
จะไปเดินเล่นอาบแดดเหมือนกันหรอใช่ค่ะปู
ไปอาบแดดนี่จะเป็นบาร์บีคิวแล้วนะคะอร่อย
นะคะต้องอร่อยนะคะไม่ได้ไม่ใช่ปูก็ไปเดิน
ไงเพราะว่าปกติเนี่ยปูอยู่ใน
รูอืสมัปูเนี่ยมันต้องอยู่ข้างในใช่มนี้
เป็นชายหาดเนี่ยปูก็จะอยู่ในรูแบบนี้ใช่
ไหมอ่าเนี่ยในรูแบบนี้ปูอยู่ในรูอืแต่ถ้า
อากาศดีเนี่ยปูก็ขึ้นมาจากรูก็เหมือนมา
อาบแดดไงครูฟ้า
อืใช่แล้วค่ะครูหญิงนั่นแหละแม่ปูก็เลย
บอกว่าไปเดินเล่นอาบแดดกันดีกว่าลูกปูก็
บอก
ว่าเอ่อเราเนี่ยไปเดินเล่นไกลๆเลยได้ยอ๋อ
ไม่อยากอยู่บริเวเอ่อไม่อยากอยู่ตรงนี้
แล้วเบื่อเดินเล่นที่นี่ทุกวันทุกวันทุก
วันเนี่ยจำได้แล้วอย่างเงี้ยหรออืใช่อยาก
ไปเดินเล่นไกลๆ
อโอนะไกลขนาดไหนอ่ะใช่ไกลขนาดไหนบ้านอยู่
ที่นี่ก็
เดินอีกซัก 20 กมเงี้ยเหรอไกลๆ 20 ใช่ค่ะ
เดินไกลๆนะคะแม่ปูก็บอกว่าโอเคอากาศดีแบบ
นี้เนี่ยอากาศดีๆเนี่ยนะคะเดินไกลแม่โอเค
อืมค่ะนั่นแหละนะคะและแม่ปูกับลูกปูเนี่ย
ก็เดินไปด้วยกันเดินๆเดินๆต๊อก๊๊ตตแต๊ก
ตอกแต๊กตอกแต๊กตอกแต๊กตอกแต๊กตอกแต๊กอัน
นี้เดินนะคะใช่ค่ะเดินไปด้วยกันค่ะ
ระหว่างที่กำลังเดินไปด้วยกัน
เนี่ยแม่ปูกับลูกปูเนี่ยก็เดินผ่าน
ครอบครัวของปูนะคะ
อืมีปูอีกครอบครัวหนึ่งครอบครัวสี
แดงมีอีกเยอะเลยนะคะปูๆปูๆๆๆก็เดิน
ผ่านปูหลายๆครอบครัวใช่ไหมยปูปูๆๆๆๆนะคะ
ซึ่งครอบครัวปูเนี่ยก็ออกมาเดินเล่นออกมา
อาบแดดออกมาร้องเพลงเพราะว่าวันนี้อากาศ
ดีไงค่ะออเหมือนกันใช่มยเหมือนแม่ปูกับ
ลูกปูคู่นี้ใช่มั้ปูทุกตัวที่อยู่ที่ชาย
หาดก็ออกมาอาบแดดเหมือนกันใช่แล้วก็มีการ
พูดกันคุยกันนะคะโอเหมือนปาร์ตี้นิดๆมย
ใช่ัม Party นะคะปาร์ตี้ตอนเมถูกต้องค่ะ
ก็เลยมีบ้านปูเนี่ยบ้านนึงนะคะปูเนี่ยก็
ออกมาเซฮัลโหลกับแม่ปู
สวัสดีสวัสดีเออ 2 แม่ลูกจะไปไหนกันนะคะ
อ๋อถามด้วยถามอืแม่ปูกับลูกปูเนี่ยจะไป
ไหนกันจ๊ะ
ค่ะแม่ปูก็บอกว่าสวัสดีจ้าวันนี้เนี่ยฉัน
จะพาลูกปูนะคะไปเดินเล่นตรง
นู้นอ๋อก็คือไกลนะคะถ้าได้ยินแบบว่าตรง
นู้นเนี่ยไกลใช่ไปเดิเล่นตรงนู้นนะคะ
อ้านั่นสิวันนี้อากาศดีมากๆเลยถ้าอย่าง
งั้นก็ขอให้เที่ยวให้สนุกนะอ่าครอบครัวปู
ครอบครัวนี้ใช่มยก็บอกว่าเที่ยวให้สนุกนะ
เที่ยวให้สนุกนะอ่าแล้วก็บอกว่าบ๊ายบายนะ
คะแม่ปูก็บอกว่าขอบคุณมากนะไปแล้วนะบ๊าย
บายนะคะและแม่ปูก็พาลูกปูเดินต่อไปค่ะ
แล้วไปเจออะไรอีกมั้ยคะไปเจออะไรอีกมั้ย
ระว่างระหว่างที่กำลังเดินนะคะครูหญิงค่ะ
แม่ปูเนี่ยก็หันมาคุยกับลูก
ปูคุยอะไร
อืนี่ลูกเห็นมว่าเด็กๆบ้านนั้นน่ะบ้านนี้
นะคะเนี่ย
อืครอบครัวเนี้ยครอบครัวนี้เนี่ยนะคะ
เพราะครอบครัวนี้ก็มีแม่ปูใช่มยอืแล้วก็
มีลูกปู
[เพลง]
อืลูกเห็นมว่าเด็กๆบ้านนั้นเนี่ยเดินไม่
ตรงเลยะอันนี้คือเดินตรงแต่ว่าเดินยังไง
เดินอย่างงี้เหรอเดินไม่ตรงเวลาปูเดินนะ
นักเรียนปูมันจะ
เดินเดินซ้ายเดินขวาเดินซ้ายเดินขวาซ้าย
ขวาซ้ายขวาอ้ามันจะเดินแบบ
นี้ซ้ายแล้วก็ขวาแล้วก็ซ้ายแล้วก็ขวาอ๋อ
มันจะเดินซิกแซกใช่มยใช่ปูไงใช่มยก็จะ
เดินเซ้ายขซขวาอันนี้ซ้ายอันนี้ขวานะ
สมมุตินะคะนักเรียนซ้ายแล้วก็ขวาแล้วก็
ซ้ายแล้วก็ขวาแต่ถ้าปกติเวลาเราเดินเรา
เดินแบบนี้ใช่ไหมเราเนี่ยเดินตรง
อ๋อแล้วยังไงต่อคะนั่นแหละแม่ก็เลยหันมา
บอกว่าลูกเห็นมยเด็กบ้านนั้นน่ะลูกๆของ
ครอบครัวนั้นเดินไม่ตรงเลยเดินซ้ายทีขวา
ทีนะคะเฮ้ยไม่โอเคเลยนะ
อืแล้วยังไงต่อลูกปูก็เลยบอกว่า
เห็นแต่ก็ไม่มันก็โอเคนี่ใช่มยลูกปูก็บอก
ว่าโอเคนี่ก็ปกติอืธรรมดาใช่มั้ยปูเดิน
ซ้ายขวาซ้ายขวาซ้ายขวาเนี่ยปกติปู 8,000
ตัวเดินเหมือนกันอืซ้ายแล้วก็ขวาซ้ายขวา
นะคะแต่แม่ปูเนี่ยบอกว่าไม่ปกตินะทำไมอ่ะ
ทำไมแม่ปูคิดว่าไม่
ปกติแม่คิดว่ามันไม่โอเคมันต้องเดินตรงๆ
ใช่มยเดินๆๆๆอย่างนี้ไม่ใช่เดินซ้ายขวา
ซ้ายขวาอันเนี้ยมันไม่ปกติอืมงี้โอเคค่ะ
ไหนลูกเดินให้แม่ดูหน่อยอ๋อแม่ปูเนี่ยบอก
ให้ลูกปูเดินแล้วลูกปูเดินมั้ยคะเดินให้
ดูหน่อยใช่ค่ะลูกปูก็เลยเดินให้แม่ดูนะคะ
เดินๆๆเดินให้แม่ดูแต่ลูกปูเนี่ยก็เหมือน
กับปูตัวอื่นๆใช่มั้ยอีก 8 คัน
ที่อยู่ด้วยกันอยู่ด้วยกันนะคะก็คือเดิน
ซ้ายทีขวาทีซ้ายขวาซ้ายขวาซ้าย
[เพลง]
ขวาก็คือเดินเป็นตัว m&m เนี่ยนะคะ M แ M
สนุกค่ะ
อ่าแล้วแม่ปูเห็นลูกปูเดินไม่ตรงเหมือน
กันแม่ปูเห็นมยเห็นแม่ปูก็เลยบอกว่าเฮ้
ทำไมลูกเดินแบบนี้ล่ะอื
ทำไมเดินเหมือนปูครอบครัวนั้น
เลยทำไมทำไมอืเดินเหมือนปูอันนี้เลยนะคะ
ทำไมเดินเหมือนปูครอบครัว
นี้อ่ะเอาอย่างนี้นะเดี๋ยวแม่จะเดินให้ดู
ค่ะอืแล้วแม่ปูก็เดินให้ลูกปูดูเหรอคะใช่
ค่ะจากนั้นแม่ปูก็เลยเดินๆๆๆให้ลูกลูกปู่
ดูนะคะซึ่งแล้วเป็นยังไงลูกปู่ก็ยืนดูก็
เห็นแม่ปู่เนี่ยเดินซ้ายขวาซ้ายขวาซ้าย
ขวาซ้ายขวาเหมือนกันแม่ปู่ก็เดินแบบนี้
ซ้ายขวา
ออแล้วลูกปูพูดอะไรมยคะลูกปูก็ไม่ได้พูด
อะไรนะคะแต่ว่าก็งงมาก
อือืมแม่ปู่เนี่ยก็เดินๆๆแล้วก็
สะดุด
ล้มเพราะว่าพยายามจะเดินให้ตรง
อ่าอืแม่ปูเนี่ยก็พยายามแบบอาจจะเดิน
อย่างนี้ก็ได้
เนาะ
อออืมพยายามจะเดินตรงๆนะคะแต่ทำไม่ได้ก็
เลยล้มลง
อือืก็เลยเป็นอย่างงี้นะ
คะเห็น
ท้อง
ลมแล้วทำแม่ปูเนี่ยนะคะอายมากทำไมลมอาย
ลูกปูเหรอใช่อายลูกปูมากเลยนะคะ
และแม่ก็เลยไม่กล้าบอกลูกหรือว่าสอนลูก
อีกเลยเพราะว่าแม่ก็ทำไม่ได้เหมือนกันแม่
ก็เดินไม่ตรงใช่มั้ยไม่ตรงเนี่ยเดินไม่
ได้แม่ก็ซ้ายขวาซ้ายขวาซ้ายขวาเหมือน
กัน
จบจบแล้วนิทานเรื่อง
นี้บอกอะไรหรอคะจบแล้วจบแล้วค่ะก็ถ้าเรา
จะสอนคนอื่น
ใช่ไหมสอนเนี่ยนะคะหรือว่าบ่อคนอื่นบางที
เราก็ต้องทำให้ได้ก่อนอ๋อเหมือนแม่ปูใช่
มั้ยใช่เราต้องเป็นตัวอย่างที่ดีก่อนนะคะ
เหมือนแม่ปู่นั่นแหละถ้าแม่ปูเดินตรงๆได้
ก็ถึงจะสอนลูกปูให้เดินตรงๆได้เหมือนกัน
อือ๋อเพราะว่าลูกปูก็ต้องดูจากแม่ปูอือ่า
ถ้าแม่ปูทำไม่ได้ไม่ได้บอกลูกปูให้ทำลูก
ก็แบบทำไมต้องทำก็แม่ก็ทำไม่ได้
เออใช่มั้ยอืก็เหมือนถ้าครูหญิงสูบบุหรี่
อืใช่มั้ยครูหญิงเนี่ยสูบบุหรี่นะคะค่ะ
สูบบุหรี่แล้วก็บอกครูฟ้าครูฟ้าสูบบุหรี่
เนี่ยไม่ดีนะครูฟ้าห้ามสูบบุหรี่แต่ครู
หญิงเนี่ยสูบ
บุหรี่ครูฟ้าจะทำตามครูหญิงมั้ยครูหญิง
พูดไม่ดีไม่ดีสูบบุหรี่ไม่ดีแต่ครูหญิง
สูบบุหรี่ให้ครูฟ้าดูครูหญิงเนี่ยทำไม่
ได้ใช่มั้ยใช่นะคะครูฟ้าก็เอ้าครูหญิงยัง
ทำเลยทำไมไม่ดีถ้าไม่ดีครูหญิงก็ต้องไม่
ทำใช่ใช่ไหมก็อาจจะหมายถึงแบบเวลาพ่อแล้ว
ก็แม่ใช่มั้ยแล้วก็ลูกเวลาพ่อแม่จะบอกลูก
สอนลูกคุณพ่อกับคุณแม่ต้องทำให้ได้ก่อน
ถึงจะบอกลูกได้อเนาะนี้ก็เป็นฟังเสร็จ
แล้วอยากกินปูเลยค่ะนักเรียนเดี๋ยวครู
หญิงจะให้ครูฟ้าไปหาปูมาให้ครูหญิงกินนะ
คะเนทานดีๆแต่เดี๋ยวเรามาเจอกันใหม่วดีโอ
หน้านะคะสวัสดีค่ะสวัสดีค่ะบ๊ายบาย